you're worth
what would it take for you to forgive
either Tom or Raquel that's not
happening
[Applause]
any more time on this clown than you
need
finale Ariana Maddox dropped
drop day during a media blitz you seem
like a completely over it now I wouldn't
say I think it's a slow process to get
there do you believe that Tom and Raquel
are in love I don't really know that
either of them knows what that word
means there were reports today that they
broke up I don't buy that at all I
regret ever loving you
Tom and Raquel are getting hammered post
finale on social media there's this
Mortal Kombat meme this Tick Tock of
their scene getting booed
and this tweet the only thing Tom
Sandoval has been faithful to is his
white nail polish you guys bought a
house together and he's still living
there speaking for some women in the
country I mean why haven't you burned
the house down to the ground I mean I
can't afford to do that yeah you know we
are joint on it 50 50. so that's the
name of that movie with Michael Douglas
I want to be a homeowner on my own yeah
after this other Unforgettable finale
moments
Sandoval's massive anxiety attack this
confession so other than Miami girl this
is the first time you've ever cheated on
Ariana
was one other time
and the bizarre way Tom blamed Ariana
for not uncovering the affair sooner all
she would have had to do is follow me
but you could say the real drama is just
beginning you can't think of
one of the
were you super selfish selfish does not
cover it diabolical demented
sub-human which leads us to the big
question who's back for next season I
think I'll be back if they'll have me
back I'll be back I think they'll have
you back
Vanderpump's EP told variety contract
negotiations are on pause right now to
give the cast an emotional break and
while Schwartz and Sandoval are expected
for season 11 Raquel's return is unclear
I mean that's not up to me I can't
control any of that I have no interest
in speaking to either of them I don't
have anything to say and also just be in
a room with them I don't plan can you
make those sort of boundaries for
yourself in reality TV um usually no but
I'll try